[Applaudissements]
du coup la vérité mon paga est ce que
c'est vrai ou est ce qu'elle était au
courant est ce que vous allez vous vous
êtes revenu en samba tout à fait vous
appartenez pas rancunière à les
abandonner
c'est très difficile en ce moment bah
oui mais c'est normal d'être accusé
tonnes il faut faire le canard vous
faire le koala et pour revenir c'est
franchement c'est pas du feq
vraiment je pouvais le dire ok et à
pâtisser il ya rien qui est scénarisé
après certes le producteur c'est le
business de gloire du héros le produit
arrive un devoir
bagapch a pris la bonne décision pas
mais aucun moment il te met le couteau
sous la gorge mais ils vous disent que
va son arrivée le couteau sous la gorge
fait une prise de judo d'entrée au moins
on en parle plus mais agace que vous lui
avez dit noter quelques cas relevés
balladur a sonné à ce que la bulle quand
même et c'est on vous l'a dit de lui
dire ce terme là non mais ça n'est pas
dans mon couple depuis depuis six mois
je l'aï battu avec l'acia non pas du
tout l'abbé ouais je sais a dit que ça
écoute je t'es trompé mais on sera
ensemble non je vous explique pourquoi
les raisons je n'avais plus de séduction
et j'avais plus rien avec cette fille et
la lexus est revenu parce que j'étais
croire les aime à pardonner elle a
reconnu ses erreurs alors aucun numéro
un petit changement qui sans pet moi je
change de couleur de cheveux tous les
mois je me serais pas m'y avait pas plu
aux papilles pau à nantes à pipo non non
et là vous allez reprendre et c'est
vraiment la femme de votre vie c'est la
femme de ma vie
ah ouais donc wave levada ma vie avec
des petites escale non non non si la
femme m'a laissé la fin de l'année faut
qu'il fasse gaffe quand même non non
parce que si c'est la femme de ta vie
la loi même si elle est un petit écart
de sport dans l'ansa tient aussi à
cession atteint sûr on sait que les
images montrent ce qu'ils veulent ah
d'accord mais alors et on est filmé 24
sur 24
et j'ai pas dis que ça j'ai par du thé
chez ta couleur du cheval ils ont garé
dans le plus sulfureux ou est ce qui va
faire tenir le spectacle espéré tout ce
qui était championnat les primo je
l'avais dit je t'aime je te jure je lève
la main droite
oui bonjour à tous
on nous dit j'ai pas très cher et pas
tricher ou trois jours d'absence les
téléspectateurs est ce que fait qu'à 57
% pas fake à 43 pour l'aca ce laps de
temps d'avancé parce qu'il ya quand même
dit était parti avec une plus jeune
était subi c'est son âge mais c'est vrai
look exactement travers des bagarres
tous car il a répondu poignard
[Applaudissements]